so I'm sitting here talking to my friend
cause I'm about to go on a first date
and I'm a little bit nervous cause I haven't been on a first date
but it's like a bar in a while um
and we're going to like a museum
anyways I'm fixing here cause I have time to kill
and I'm nervous and talk to my friend
and I touch the side of my face
he's gonna be here in 20 minutes
I put some gum try and fix
I have super glue but the super glue won't work
I have nailglue but like
it doesn't stick so I needed it to stick to something
so I put a little bit of gum
that's not working my friends are gonna go try and find gel super glue
he’s here in 20 minutes and these are my favorite glasses
whoever evil eyed me you are so wrong for that so wrong for that